Я пишаюся, що живу в одному з найбільш дружніх до ЛГБТК міст Німеччини.
Це Кельн!
Приблизно кожен десятий житель міста відносить себе до ЛГБТК. І це помітно.
У спільноти тут є клуби, бари, кабаре, перший у Європі спортклуб, карнавальне об'єднання і навіть свій різдвяний ринок.
В актуальному рейтингу терпимості країн до ЛГБТК Німеччина зайняла 16-те місце з 49 країн Європи.
Піднятися вище завадили випадки дискримінації і мови ворожнечі.
Тож як воно насправді -  жити в Німеччині, будучи гомосексуалом?
Я біла жінка, не живу у злиднях, у мене все добре.
Багато людей і не підозрюють, що я лесбійка.
Але якщо запитати представників ЛГБТК з інших культур - вони стикаються навіть у Німеччині,
в Берліні з проявами трансфобії і гомофобії, злочинами на ґрунті ненависті.
Є дуже багато сфер, де неймовірно важко відкрито бути геєм, де ми зазнаємо багато дискримінації.
Виростати у сільській місцевості мені як трансгендеру було важко.
У такій місцевості діють суворі норми, особливо щодо статей, і не відповідати їм було дуже неприємно.
У провінції жити важче, тому що без спільноти ви самотні, а це велика проблема.
Німеччина ніколи не була першопрохідцем. А мені б хотілося бачити Німеччину сміливішою в цій сфері.
Наприклад, у Німеччині чоловікам-геям усе ще заборонено здавати кров, немає гідного закону для транссексуалів.
У фокус громадської потрапляє дедалі більше тем, які нас у спільноті вже давно хвилюють.
Тепер їх нарешті обговорюють люди, яких вони безпосередньо не стосуються.
Чи знаєте ви, що одним із перших захисників прав геїв і трансгендерів був німець?
Магнус Гіршфельд, єврейський лікар і сексолог ще на початку XX століття публічно вимагав скасування гомофобних законів у Німеччині.
Зокрема, він виступав проти параграфа 175, який визначав стосунки між чоловіками як злочин.
Хоча закон так і не змінили, у Німеччині часів Веймарської республіки до спільноти геїв ставилися терпимо, особливо в Берліні.
Усе різко змінилося з приходом до влади Гітлера.
Інститут сексуальних досліджень Гіршфельда був знищений, його книги спалені, а сам він змушений емігрувати з країни.
Нацисти розширили параграф 175 і використовували його для арештів десятків тисяч чоловіків.
Багато з них були відправлені в концтабори, де їх мітили рожевим трикутником на уніформі.
Лесбійські стосунки не вважали злочином у нацистській Німеччині, але й жінок переслідували і змушували до екзилу.
Тоді як у НДР одностатеві стосунки перестали переслідувати з кінця 1950-их років,
гомосексуальність залишалася кримінальним злочином і у Західній, і в Східній Німеччині до кінця 1960-их.
І лише в 1994 році параграф 175 зник із законів возз'єднаної Німеччини.
Певний прогрес також досягли останніми роками.
У 2017 році Німеччина легалізувала одностатеві шлюби.
Але в порівнянні з гетеросексуальним шлюбом є ще певна нерівність.
Зокрема в питанні отримання батьківських прав.
З 2018 року інтерсексуали в Німеччині отримали можливість реєструватися з гендером "інше" замість традиційних "чоловік" і "жінка".
А ще - більше не потрібно давати дитині ім'я, яке ясно вказує на його статеву приналежність.
А ось боротьба за модернізацію "закону про транссексуалів" триває.
Ухвалений ще у 1980-их роках, він робить процедуру зміни імені довгим і дорогим процесом.
Є ще спірний "тест на повсякденність": транссексуали повинні прожити в своїй новій гендерній ідентичності мінімум рік.
І тільки тоді медична страховка дасть добро на операцію зі зміни статі або гормональну терапію.
Я пройшла процедуру офіційної зміни імені.
Це було не тільки дорого - кілька тисяч євро, але і вкрай неприємно:
розкривати незнайомим людям все своє життя під час багатьох довгих засідань,
повідомляти інтимні подробиці моєї сексуальності, щоб суд міг винести рішення про мою статеву приналежність.
Нам не потрібен особливий закон.
Все, що стосується нас - цивільний статус, ім'я, шлюб, сім'я - для всього цього вже є закони.
Їх потрібно просто застосовувати і до нас.
І все це на основі самовизначення. Я знаю, хто я і що я.
Публічність важлива для будь-якої меншини.
Важливими віхами для становлення ЛГБТК-спільноти у Німеччині стали…
суперечливий фільм про гомосексуалів на кінофестивалі "Берлінале" в 1971 році,
гей-поцілунок в популярному телесеріалі "Лінденштрассе" в 1990 році,
а також камінг-аут мера Берліна у 2001 році: "Я гей, і це добре!"
Однак якщо говорити по улюблений національний спорт -
футбол, то досі жоден професійний гравець не зробив каміг-аут упродовж своєї кар'єри.
Раз на рік, зазвичай у червні або липні, в багатьох містах Німеччини проходять гей-паради і демонстрації.
Вам, можливо, більш знайома назва "CSD", що означає Christopher Street Day - за назвою вулиці,
де 1969 року в Нью-Йорку пройшли протести, які поклали початок всесвітньому руху "прайд".
Прайд завжди був і буде важливим.
Це простір і час, коли можна відкрито показати наше існування,
коли ти видимий і можеш вийти на демонстрацію, показавши, що є частиною суспільства.
Ось чому це надважливо для мене!
Для мене це не так важливо.
Звичайно, чудово, що з часом гей-паради перетворилися на таку величезну подію.
Але я не думаю, що політика робиться на прайдах.
Прайд залишатиметься політичною подією, поки є права, яких немає у спільноти ЛГБТК.
Навіть якщо 30 років тому нам доводилося більше боротися за свої права, прайд усе ще потрібний.
Політичні ситуації можуть дуже швидко змінюватися.
Поки веселковий прапор на футбольному стадіоні - проблема,
поки в збірній офіційно немає геїв,
поки сільські підлітки ще вимушені боятися відкритися, нам потрібен прайд.